génial artiste que je kiffe mais il ya
aussi le pote mais c'est vrai quoi la
chaux qui fait écouter des chansons je
suis très heureux pour toi parce que ça
cartonne et j'ai un cadeau pour toi mon
chéri des choix regarde des triple
disque de platine noir c'est quoi ça
fait ça fait un mois que je le sais mais
que j'avais pas il me l'avait pas eh ben
voilà est basse et toi tu mets avec
sissy bar avec 0 je le mets dans les
staffs et de raymond lourd et c'est
magnifique magnifique mais c'est ben
voilà ça déjà c'est pourquoi monsieur
mon mac dix sept ans de carrière en asie
cet arrière frérot 1317 alors on va
parler plein de choses avec toi juste
avant jouer et qu'on regarde deux titres
sandales et si on si on disait de titres
que je kiffe l'album voit la pyramide et
pilote qui cartonne je m'en rappelle et
je me rappellerai toujours j'espère que
c'est porter chance parce que tu nous
avais à malik et moi planète on exclut
avec le clip tous les deux un soir en
train de bouffer une crêpe c'est vrai
enfin nous nous sommes connus nos gardes
comme témoin bouffer une crêpe et lui
nous regarder j'adore c'est la cour si
on
pour qu'on voit plus être encore à et
malik bentalha moi je suis lié au choix
qui nous dit la semana bentalha et cyril
hanouna
on est en train de se dénoncer tant de
carrières huit albums plus de 5 millions
d'années avec des crêpes
j'étais à 23h30 albums vendus cette
tournée 16 nrj music hall alarm un peu
plus je penserai plus valoir dont on
parlera des nerfs du midi commandant
instant 12 millions de fask il était une
heure du matin on est en train de se
démonter que des crêpes au nutella and
sur les réseaux sociaux est d'ailleurs à
william hague qui nous rejoint
l'hématome frère prend une crue un
talent c'est un truc de fou pour heures
pour les femmes à will help
c'est bon ça va me faire écouter en fait
on a commencé et nous avait écoutés le
bas si nous c'est notre éducation qui
s'appelle in life strictes et les
planètes et la sai a voulu aller et nous
en fait c'est vraiment le truc avec les
réseaux sociaux avec ce qui fait le show
c'est bien en touche